Парк корупції нагадує ящірку, яка,  як і корупція, пролізе усюди.
Експозиція у вигляді золотого батона
екс-президента України Віктора Януковича.
Її сенс - показати, що корупція – це явище не нове.
Золотий батон Януковича – далеко не єдиний
відомий на весь світ символ корупції.
Інтерактивна композиція розповідає про Румунію.
Там - найвищий рівень корупції в ЄС.
А також про те, що рівень корупції в Україні
нижчий, ніж у Росії, але вищий, ніж у Білорусі.
У золотому батоні зібрані різні гучні історії
збагачення можновладців з усього світу.
Причому і сучасності, і стародавніх часів.
У Київській Русі за корупцію, до речі, одразу вбивали.
В Китаї спочатку жорстоко катували.
В сучасній Україні корупціонерам вдається ухилятися
від відповідальності і перетворювати свої незаконні статки...
...на автомобілі. За цей один із корупціонерів сплатив 250 000 євро.
...на предмети інтер’єру. Вартість такої люстри - 8 мільйонів євро.
Цих коштів вистачило би одній українській родині
на електроенергію упродовж 64 000 років!
Ця експозиція під назвою "Кімната корупціонера" -
своєрідний квест із метою вплинути на підсвідомість людей.
Коли якийсь корупціонер украв мільйон доларів,
для нас це незрозуміло. Коли ми пояснюємо людині,
що він у вас і ще у тисячі людей вкрав
обіди в дитячому садку, і внаслідок цього хтось недоїдає,
то, нам здається, це буде більш зрозуміло для людей.
Це - одна з найцікавіших кімнат.
Такий собі тренінг: як знаходити докази хабарництва
в кабінеті корупціонера на ім’я Степан Хабарченко.
Ось, наприклад, гроші. Купюри з позначками, написано: "Хабар".
Можна відчути себе справжнім детективом,
можна і корупціонером. Кімната "Сни корупціонера".
Вони спочатку світлі, але в кінці - суцільні жахи.
Якби рівень корупції в Україні за останні 10 років
знизився хоча б удвічі, економіка могла б додатково виробити товарів та послуг
на суму 25 мільярдів євро.
Гроші, що вкрали корупціонери, українці вже ніколи не побачать.
Проте, можуть долучитися до боротьби з корупцією.
Парк корупції – це частина масштабного проекту
антикорупційної ініціативи ЄС в Україні. Його мета –
мотивувати людей не втомлюватися від розмов про корупцію,
а активно їй протидіяти.